- Happy holidays, everybody.
I'm back with Gwen Stefani
in our winter wonderland.
Give it up for Miss Gwen Stefani.
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
In normal times, Gwen and
I both like to decorate,
and host get togethers, Christmas maybe.
I do miss people.
Do you miss people?
- I do.
- So let's reminisce about times gone by
that soon will be again,
and find out, wait for it,
who is the Chrismostest Hostess?
♪ The Christmostest Hostess ♪
Oh my God, that's horribly awesome.
Okay, I hadn't heard that yet.
Good job, guys.
Here to oversee the
festivities is comedian,
and host of The Cabin with
Bert Kreischer on Netflix,
give it up for Bert Kreischer, everybody.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it's good to meet you.
- [Kelly] It's nice to meet you.
- Good to meet you ladies.
- Yes, yes.
- First, I gotta start off,
big fan of both of you.
- Thank you.
- Big fan of both of you.
- Even if you're lying,
I love it.
(Gwen laughing)
- No, I am definitely not lying.
(Kelly laughing)
I am definitely not lying.
- Well, what's up with you?
How are you?
How are things?
- I'm doing fantastic.
(Kelly laughing)
These might be a thing
that works.
- Can I just touch you
the whole time?
(Bert laughing)
Just keep going.
Well, tell us about the game, Bert.
Just tell us.
- It's super simple, okay?
I'm gonna ask you guys a series
of questions about Christmas.
If you know the answer,
use these ridiculously long
arms to smash the button
on the podium.
Kelly.
- Yes.
- You are going to be playing
for the right side of the audience,
and Gwen you're playing for
the left side of the audience.
Get it right, and you get a point.
Get it wrong, and you have to chug one
of your holiday themed
cocktails on your tray.
- Oh, see, this might be the
first time I try and lose.
(Kelly laughing)
- Winner gets a cool prize
for her side of the audience,
and I just want you guys to know,
this is one of the coolest prizes
this show has ever given away ever.
- Boom.
- And if Gwen wins, she
also gets her photo mounted
- Yes!
- On the Blake Shelton
Wall of Champions who beat Kelly Clarkson.
(audience cheering)
- It's rude, it's a rude gift he gave me.
- Yes, right next to Billy Gardell.
- Exactly, oh, there's so many up there.
- Who I party with a lot.
(Kelly laughing)
- Now, because Blake's about
to become Mr. Gwen Stefani,
(Kelly laughing)
Kelly, yeah,
or I'm going with either.
- Yeah, whatever
you want to do, it's 2020, yeah.
- Yeah, whatever he wants
to choose to be, yep.
Kelly gets to remove
Blake's photo from the wall.
Ladies, are you ready?
(audience laughing)
- I am so ready.
- All right, here we go.
- Okay.
(festive music)
- According to legend,
what holiday goodies are shaped
as a shepherd staff to remind children...
- Oh, oh, oh.
- Of the shepherds
who visited baby Jesus?
(buzzer beeping)
Gwen!
- Candy cane!
- Candy canes is a winner.
- Woo!
- I didn't know that.
- One point for Gwen.
I didn't know that.
- Kelly, Kelly, you've gotta chug.
- I didn't know, damn straight.
- So, wait, you didn't know that?
- Which one?
I didn't know that.
- Can I tell you,
I didn't know that either?
- Kelly, Kelly, come on.
- I thought it was just that way
'cause they put up the tree.
- You're letting me win.
- He didn't know it.
- I swear to God.
- No, I didn't know that.
- When I read the thing,
I swear to God, I thought it
was just so they put on trees.
- Do you know what I was gonna go with?
- [Gwen] Okay.
- I was gonna go with a cinnamon stick
because it looks like that.
I didn't know, I'm going
to go for a mulled wine.
- Mulled wine.
Because I'm sophisticated, Gwen and Bert.
- Prayer works, you guys.
I prayed before I came out.
(audience laughing)
- Wait, I did too.
(Gwen laughing)
- Oh, that's really good.
- You're my new best friend.
- So, my staff can make
a really good drink.
- [Gwen] Is it good, for real?
- Okay, next question.
- I got this one.
- What vegetable
is a Christmas item that
serves both as a reindeer food,
and as a snowman's nose?
Kelly!
- Carrot!
- [Bert] Carrot's a winner.
(buzzer beeps)
One point for Kelly.
- Carrot.
- Gwen, time to chug.
(audience cheering)
- Which one are you gonna choose, Stefani?
- Okay, I was told backstage, this one.
- Well nobody told me...
- That's a good one.
- A great one, what?
- What's that one called?
- Puerto Rican Cocito?
- Yes.
- A cocito?
- Yes, thank you.
- Cocoa-jito, like a mojito
but with cocoa?
- You know what?
Let me just try it with you.
- [Bert] Might as well try it.
- Oh my God, that is
thick, like wow, that is...
- Oh my gosh.
- I'm kind of bummed out
at whoever produced
this segment right now.
I am sitting here dry.
(Kelly laughing)
- You are, this is rude.
The Kelly Clarkson Show sucks for Bert.
- I'd would share, but COVID.
- [Kelly] That's really good.
(laughing)
- I would share but COVID,
that's gonna be my new one.
Sorry, guys, there's more
bottles of wine for me, COVID.
(laughing)
- Okay, I'm ready.
- All right, ladies.
Last question.
- Okay.
- Worth five points.
- Oh, she's feeling it,
she got competitive.
I like this.
- You know what?
I am.
- You're both gonna know
this, so really get ready.
- Okay.
- I'm on the right side.
- How do you say Merry
Christmas in Spanish?
(buzzer beeps)
(Kelly groaning)
That's Gwen, that's Gwen, Gwen?
- What?
(speaks in foreign language)
(buzzer beeps)
- Oh, bingo.
(speaks in foreign language)
(audience cheering)
- Gwen, you are the winner,
and I will place this...
- Did I hit that first?
- Where is the left side?
- I hit that first, I
would like a playback,
but it's fine.
(audience cheering)
- This is literally monumental for me.
- I'm not taking it from you.
Get on that wall with your fiance.
- All right, here we go,
right next to Billy Gardell.
(victorious music)
- All right, whatever.
- I can't believe Billy Gardell
is next to Natalie Portman.
- Yes, wow.
- See, look how much cooler
you are than Blake, how did that happen?
(Gwen laughing)
Look at that photo.
All right, that means everyone
on the left side of the house seat
is also a winner.
(audience cheering)
But it's Christmas, so what the hell,
you're all getting it,
so Miraval Resorts is
one of the country's leading
destination spa brands,
with locations in Tucson,
Austin, and the Berkshire's,
with cutting edge spa
treatments, farm to table dining,
guided hikes, equine programs,
unlimited yoga and fitness classes,
and spiritual counseling as well.
The all-inclusive resort is designed
to help guests feel their best
and live a life in balance.
Everyone in the house seats is getting
a four day, three night
stay at Miraval Resorts,
destination nearest you, your choice.
(audience cheering)
Have a blast, I'm a
little jealous, whatever.
All right, everybody, Merry Christmas.